>> Tucr: SA FEW DAYS AGO A
MOER IN NEW JERSEY, ANGELA
REDDING, FOU OUT HERHILD'S
EMENT O HOOL WAS
ADVEISINSOMETHING LDER
PAN SEX AOU AL
SHE OUGHT IT WASUCH AND
COMPLAINED AUT IT ON FACOOK.
WHAT HAPNED NEXTHOUL'T
HAPPEN ITHIS COUNT.
WE ONLY KNOW ABOUT IBECAUSE OFCE
STORY.
RESPONSTO AELA REDDG'S
POST OUT OF THE BLUE AN MY
FICER CALDERON ANGELA REDDIN
AANXTRESTN FACEBOOK
THEN OTE ON FACE BO THE
QUOT
JOBASED LEADERSHAVE
SERITY FORWORKG WITHMULTIPLE STW
ENRCEMT AGENCIES TO MONITOR
THE TUATION.WHAT?
SO THE MILITARRESPONDED TO A
M IN A ELENTARY SCHOOL
COMPLAIN I ABOHE
XUALIZATION OF HER OWN CHILD?TH?
APPARENTLYDID.
SHORTLAFTER THE CHIEF OF THE
NOH HAFPB OVER POLICEDEPARTMENTO
DETE H FACEBOOPOST.
LET THAT SK IN.
THPOLICE ANDILITARY GOT
INVOED BECAUSE THE MOM WTE
SOMEING ON FACOOK EY
DIDN'T LIKING.
DAY IT WAS CONFIRMEDO ESHOW, THA
ENFORCENT OUT THE EXCHANGE,COMMG
FORMION AMONG LAW
ENFORCEMENT ENCI.
WAIT A SECD, A MILITY BASE
IS NOT A "LAW FORCEMENT
ENCY" THEY AREO DEFEND US
AGAIT FOREIGN ENIES NOTPOLICE FT
TH IS MIND BOGGLING AND WE
PRAY SOMEO DS METHING
ABOUT IT.
ANLA JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOBEING BRAVE OUGH
TO CE THIS.
WERE YOU SPRISED TILITARY
WEHED  ON YOUR FACEBOOK
PO.
I W MORTHAN SURPRED.
I WASCARED.I PULLEDY KI FROM HOE
DAY I FOUND OU
IT WAS MD BOGGLING.
WHEN THE U.S. MILITARY COMES
AFTER YOU OUT RAISINCONCERN
ON A PUBLIPOSTER AVAILABLE F
ALL TO SEE.
IT'S BIND BOLING
>>O CLEAROU WE NOT
REATENING WAR, ONUCLRWEAPONS AG.
>> AUALLY MY POST WA
DERA.
IT SD DIDN'THINKY
7-YE-OLD WAS, IT W AGEAPPROPRIA.
I SAID ALL PEOPLE ARE DERVIN
OFOVE AND RESPECT.
POSWAEXPLICIT ABOUT THAT.
ITTILL PMPTED THIS RESPONSE.
'S REALLY SCARY INHIS
COUNY WE C'T HE A RIGHTOSPEAK A.
>> Tucr: Y LIVE IN AAREA
WITH LOTF MILITARY FAMILIE
YOUR CHILDN'S SCHOOLAS A LOTOF .
U RESPECT E MILITARY.
ALST ALL ARICANSO.
DO YOU KNOW THEY REAYOUR
FACEOKOSTS.
>> I DID NOT
WANTO BE EXPLIT.
BELIE R MILITARY PERNNEL
DERVTHUPMOST LE D
SPECT.
I'M THE UGHTER OA VERAN.
I VE IN A COMMUNITY WITH
MILITARY.
THESE ARE PHOMENAL FAMILIETHSCHL
TEACHERS IN R DISTRICTREPHENOME.
I THINK  ROLL UGE, BAD
FACED ACTOR AND  DON'T NEED TO
IMPLICATE THENTIOPULION.
I DID NOT THK E MITARY WAS
NITORING MOM'SACEBK STS.
NO, DID T.
>> Tker: NO, YOUOULD HE
MMANDER SCHILLG WOULBE
MOVED FR HIS COMMAND
TONIGH
WEILSEE IFE IS.
AT WAS THEOLL OF THE POLICE
CHF, CANOU TELL UICKLY?>> Y, I T
THIS
IS IS A RENT GROUP I
STED ON.I GOT A CALLROM R SANG E
POLICEHIEF CONTACTED HER
SAYINGPOST SHOULD COME DOWN.SHE.
I SAID I D'T WANT HOMELA
SECURITY CING TER .
TAKE T PT DOWN.
I DOT WA TDEALITH IS
AGREED THE POST SHOULD CE
DOWN.
I NTACTED THE POLICEHIEF
RECTLY AND RINDED HIM OF THE
RSAMENENT.
AT WE SHLDN'UTILIZE
GORNMENT RESOURC IN OUR
POSITIONS TO PRESSE
INVIDUALS TO TAKDOWN
FACEOK POSTS.
I ALSOHARED WITH H THE POST
HASEEN.
THE WAS NOTHING WRON
DIDN'T OLATE ANY LAW OR
FACEBO RULE ATSOEVER
SO, TH IS HOTHAT A
HAPPENED.
YOU KNOW WE'REERE DAY.
>>ucker: I HOPE CHIEF HUFF I
LIEV OHIS ST IMMEDTELYTOO.
I HAVE